So, uh, listener, oh boy, I have to say, I'm not, I'm not devastated. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 52 recorded on November 13th, 2021. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host Bryce, we celebrate our one year anniversary of ADSP the podcast by talking about one versus zero indexing and our favorite episodes from the past year. So I think you might have made a tactical mistake. What? How? This episode might turn out to be an episode about counting.
所以，呃，听众朋友们，天哪，我得说，我并没有，我并没有感到崩溃。欢迎来到 ADSP，这是一档播客节目，于 2021 年 11 月 13 日录制，我是康纳。今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，通过讨论从 1 到 0 的索引以及我们过去一年中最喜欢的节目，来庆祝 ADSP 播客成立一周年。所以我觉得你可能犯了一个战术错误。什么？怎么说？这期节目最后可能会变成一期关于数数的节目。
How many episodes do you think we've published? Oh, I know. We're zero index, bro. But wait, wait, wait. Here. Before we do this, I've just realized. I'll be back in a second. Hold that thought. Hold that thought. Connor is departing the podcast recording closet because, yes, that's how Connor records the podcast, in a closet. Was he going to retrieve a drink?
你觉得我们已经发布了多少期节目？哦，我知道。我们是用零索引的，老兄。但是等等，等等，等等。来。在我们做这件事之前，我刚意识到。我一会儿就回来。保留这个想法。保留这个想法。康纳离开了播客录音间，因为，是的，康纳就是在一个衣帽间里录制播客的。他是去拿饮料了吗？
We're back. We're back. Folks, we're back with the black cherry. I don't know why I'm showing Bryce because no one can see this. And here we go because it's our one-year anniversary episode, which Bryce is going to have some thoughts on in a sec. This could end up being a long-winded episode. Here we go.
我们回来了。我们回来了。各位，我们带着黑樱桃味气泡水回来了。我不知道为什么我要向布莱斯展示，因为没人能看到这个。我们要开始了，因为这是我们的一周年纪念节目，布莱斯一会儿会对它有一些感想。这最后可能会变成一个长篇大论的节目。我们开始吧。
Black cherry buble coming up. Woo! That's how we get it done. That was amazing. Bryce, share with us what you would like to about counting. Is it our one-year anniversary? Because this is going to be the 53rd episode, not the 52nd. You know what?
黑樱桃 buble 来喽。呜！这就是我们搞定它的方式。太棒了。布莱斯，跟我们分享一下你对数数的看法吧。这真的是我们的一周年纪念吗？因为这将是第 53 期节目，而不是第 52 期。你知道吗？
This is actually— We're zero indexed. I had like three things sort of planned to talk about in today's episode. Wait, wait, but how is this possible? Because episode zero was published last year on November 14th. And we've published one episode a week. That's not true. It was not published on November 14th. That's what the app says. And that's what the the the app says and that's what the
这其实是——我们是零索引的。我今天这期节目差不多计划了三件事要谈。等等，等等，但这是怎么回事？因为第 0 期节目是去年 11 月 14 日发布的。而且我们是一周发布一期节目。这不是真的。它不是在 11 月 14 日发布的。应用程序上就是这么写的。而且那那那个应用程序上就是这么写的，而且那个
write-up says it says oh no date oh date recorded yes date recorded november 14th and why folks to take a date date released november 20th correct and what is today bryce today's the 13th we'll release it on six days from now six plus 13 you can do it buddy the 19th which is one day one day on a second this is going to get really philosophical i'm excited to this is so this will be our fourth thing that we're talking about and we'll be doing it first just hang on one moment i'm hanging on there have been 52 weeks since we started this podcast. It's inclusive, bro. But then how will that be?
文稿上也写着，上面写着，哦，没有日期，哦，录制日期，是的，录制日期是 11 月 14 日。那么为什么呢，各位，发布日期是 11 月 20 日，对吧？那么今天是几号，布莱斯？今天是 13 号，我们将在从现在起六天后发布它，6 加 13，你算得出来，老兄，是 19 号，也就是，等一下，这要变得非常哲学了，我好兴奋，这将是我们要谈的第四件事，而且我们会先谈这个，稍等一会儿。我正听着呢。自从我们开始这个播客以来，已经过去 52 周了。这是包含边界的，老兄。但那样怎么会呢？
Because that will be the 53rd episode, episode number 52, because we're zero indexed. How does that math work? Disclaimer. I know that I do have a math degree, but in my defense, I was not a very good student. So this is only 10% tangential. I've really been trying to, I think about a lot of things, but one of the things I think about on a weekly basis is whether zero indexing should be the default in array languages because for those that don't know, in APL, one of the biggest mistakes that's sort of acknowledged
因为那将是第 53 期节目，第 52 号节目，因为我们是零索引的。这数学是怎么算的？免责声明。我知道我确实有一个数学学位，但为自己辩护一下，我不是一个好学生。所以这只有 10% 的题外话。我真的一直在努力，我会思考很多事情，但我每周都会思考的事情之一就是，在数组语言中，零索引是否应该成为默认设置，因为对于那些不知道的人来说，在 APL 中，被认为最大的错误之一
is they had something called quad IO. So quad was like a little rectangular Unicode box, or I guess it wasn't Unicode at all times. And then IO or whatever the one or two letters that followed it would be like a special function. And it stands for index origin, which by default is one, but you can set it to zero if you want. And so it acknowledges like the biggest mistake, not that they chose zero or one. It's choosing one is that they think is the right thing to do.
是他们有一种叫做 quad IO 的东西。所以 quad 就像一个小的矩形 Unicode 方框，或者我猜它并不总是一个 Unicode。然后 IO 或跟随它的一个或两个字母将是一个特殊函数。它代表索引起点（index origin），默认情况下是 1，但如果你愿意，可以将其设置为 0。因此，它承认最大的错误不是他们选择了 0 还是 1。选择 1 才是他们认为是正确的事情。
It's that they let you, it's basically like a global thing that affects the way algorithms works. Like for instance, IOTA, if you have index origin set to one, IOTA five is one, two, three, four, five. But if you have index origin set to zero, it's zero, one, two, three, four. So like the, you know, the state of this quad IO affects the way that certain algorithms work that are dependent on quad IO. But the thing is, is there are, so in J, they got rid of quad IO and they just defaulted sort of index origin implicitly to zero. So if you go IOTA five, you get zero, one, two, three, four in J. And it is my evolving opinion that actually one indexing is the correct default
而是他们让你，它基本上就像一个全局的东西，影响着算法的工作方式。比如，iota，如果你将索引起点设置为 1，iota 5 就是 1, 2, 3, 4, 5。但如果你将索引起点设置为 0，它就是 0, 1, 2, 3, 4。所以，你知道的，这个 quad IO 的状态会影响某些依赖于 quad IO 的算法的工作方式。但问题是，在 J 中，他们去掉了 quad IO，并且隐式地将索引起点默认设为了 0。所以在 J 中输入 iota 5，你会得到 0, 1, 2, 3, 4。我越来越觉得，其实 1 索引才是
in array languages. Because so often you're doing things where the exact problem that we're running into here, where like the fact that we have episode zero, one, two, three, and four does not correspond to first, second, third, fourth, and fifth. Like our first episode is episode zero. So we have this mismatch, which is very, it bothers me. I think it's okay in like, you know, and stuff do you have thoughts on i i no i i i i actually think it's probably not okay in c++ i mean i i zero index everything you know if i'm sending an email with a numbered list i zero index it for the simple i i've said this before on the show i'm sure uh you know bryce's law i'd rather be consistently wrong than inconsistent. That's fair.
数组语言中正确的默认设置。因为你经常会做一些事情，正是我们在这里遇到的问题，我们有第 0、1、2、3 和 4 期节目，这与第一、第二、第三、第四和第五并不对应。就像我们的第一期节目是第 0 期。所以我们有这种错配，这非常，这让我很困扰。我觉得在诸如等等的东西里这没问题，你有何看法，我我没有，我我我其实觉得在 C++ 里可能不太行，我是说，我所有东西都用零索引，你知道的，如果我发一封带编号列表的电子邮件，我也会用零索引，原因很简单，我以前在节目里说过，我确信，你知道的，布莱斯的定律：我宁愿一直错得一致，也不愿前后矛盾。这倒也是。
I live my life by that. That's fair. And so because C++ is zero-indexed, and that's the main thing I do, or at the very least, the majority of languages and programming things that I do are going to end up being zero-indexed. So then, therefore, everything else in my life are going to end up being zero indexed. So then, therefore, everything else in my life is going to be zero indexed. I'm not saying that it's the right thing. I'm just saying I'd like to be consistent.
我按这个原则生活。这倒也是。而且因为 C++ 是零索引的，这是我主要做的事情，或者至少，我做的绝大多数语言和编程事情最后都会是零索引的。所以因此，我生活中的所有其他事情最终也都会是零索引的。所以因此，我生活中的所有其他事情最终也都会是零索引的。我不是说这是正确的事情。我只是说我想保持一致。
But I think that zero indexing was probably a mistake because of the hurdle to explain it to the uninitiated. Just like off the bat, like if you are explaining something to somebody who has no programming background whatsoever, if you have to also explain zero indexing on top of that, it just adds additional complexity. Isn't it, I thought, and maybe this is a mistaken impression, that the computer science or software engineering society at large had agreed that for some reason that I don't know the motivation for,
但我认为零索引可能是一个错误，因为向新手解释它存在障碍。就像一上来，如果你向一个完全没有编程背景的人解释某事，如果你还得额外解释零索引，这只会增加额外的复杂性。难道不是吗，我以为，也许这是一个错误的印象，计算机科学或软件工程界总的来说已经达成一致，出于某种我不知道其动机的原因，
I don't know the reason that zero indexing is the correct thing. Like, do you know where it comes from? No, no, no. There's, there's a reason for that. And I mean, the reason is if you have, I mean, just, just like think about it conceptually in terms of the, the actual memory under the hood and in terms of like pointers, you know, if you have a pointer to some array or if a pointer to some like contiguous sequence of memory that represents an array, what is the address of the first element? Yeah, that makes sense.
我不知道零索引是正确做法的原因。就像，你知道它源于哪里吗？不，不，不。这里面是有原因的。我的意思是，原因在于，如果你有，我的意思是，就从底层实际内存和指针的角度在概念上考虑一下，你知道的，如果你有一个指向某个数组的指针，或者一个指向代表数组的某段连续内存的指针，第一个元素的地址是什么？对，这说得通。
Well, the address of the first element is just, you know, that pointer to the array. But I don't think that that physical reality of computers that like, you know, memory addressing works that way. I don't think that that means that that's how we should have
嗯，第一个元素的地址就是，你知道的，那个指向数组的指针。但我不认为计算机的这种物理现实，即内存寻址是那样工作的，我不认为这意味着这就是我们应该在编程语言中
logically represented it in programming languages. And I mean, you know, like if you show, if you try to explain the notion of an array to somebody who knows nothing about programming, just like think about how you'd do it. And think about how much easier it would be if you did not need to explain that there was this notion of a zeroth element. And I think it leads to a lot of common off-by-one errors. I think when you have a zero zero index based world, you tend to do half open sets where the, you know, you're, yeah,
逻辑上表示它的方式。我的意思是，你知道的，如果你展示，如果你试图向一个对编程一无所知的人解释数组的概念，就想想你会怎么做。再想想，如果你不需要解释存在着“第零个元素”这个概念，事情会变得多么简单。而且我认为这会导致许多常见的“差一错误”（off-by-one errors）。我认为当你拥有一个基于零索引的世界时，你倾向于使用半开区间，其中，你知道的，
you have a, not sets, ranges. So when you have zero index, when you have a language with zero indexing, I think the tendency is that you'll describe ranges of integers um with the the first element being inclusive and the last being exclusive um you know yeah you know the elements from like zero to n where it's not including the element n right um and and just like little disconnects like the size of an array. Right. If I ask an array, like, what size are you? I cannot use the answer to that question to get the last element. I need to subtract one. Yeah.
你拥有一个，不是集合，是范围。所以当你使用零索引时，当你使用一个带有零索引的语言时，我认为的倾向是你会用整数范围来描述，第一个元素包含在内，最后一个元素排除在外，你知道的，从 0 到 n 的元素，其中不包括元素 n，对吧？然后还有一些小的不一致，比如数组的大小。对。如果我问一个数组，“你多大了（多大尺寸）？”，我无法利用这个问题的答案来获取最后一个元素。我需要减去 1。对。
And probably thinking about it, one of the big things too, which is why probably a motivating reason why Ken Iverson chose to be one index is it doesn't map to English. When you say, oh, I need to grab the third element from this array, you need to use index two. And that's completely counterintuitive. And this is coming from a guy who named functions verbs and operators conjunctions and adverbs. And like, so he was, he was trying to map computer science and his language to literally English. And I think that gets to, you know, the crux of this decision, whether to zero index or one index. And I mentioned it a little bit a minute ago, which is, it's a question of do you model
仔细想想，其中一个重大事情，这也是肯·艾弗森（Ken Iverson）选择 1 索引的一个主要动机原因，是它与英文不对应。当你说“哦，我需要从这个数组中获取第三个元素”时，你需要使用索引 2。这完全是反直觉的。而且这是一个把函数称为动词、把操作符称为连词和副词的家伙说出来的。所以他一直在试图将计算机科学和他的语言字面映射到英语。我认为这触及了这个决定的核心，即到底是使用零索引还是一索引。我刚才稍微提了一下，这是一个问题：你是在对物理现实进行建模，还是对逻辑概念进行建模？你知道的，当你在构建一门编程语言时，你会选择一种最准确反映硬件实际工作方式、底层设施实际工作方式的表示法或设计吗？还是你会选择对程序员最自然、对人类最自然的设计？我认为在这种情况下，如果你想对计算机的实际工作方式进行建模，零索引就是你选择的选项。而如果你想对我们的思考方式、数学建模或物理建模等进行建模，一索引就是你的选择。
the physical reality or the logical concept? You know, when you're building a programming language, do you choose a representation or a design that most accurately reflects how the hardware actually works, how the underlying facilities actually work? Or do you select the design that is most natural to programmers, is most natural to humans? And I think in this case, zero indexing is the option that you pick if you want to model how the computer actually works. Whereas one indexing is what you'd pick if you want to model how we think or model mathematics or, you know, model physics, et cetera.
是的，我认为这就是为什么像 Fortran 这样专为数值和符号计算而设计的语言会选择一索引，而像 C 语言这样旨在作为系统编程语言、
Yeah. And I think that's one of the reasons why a language like Fortran, which was designed for numerical and symbolic computing, picked one indexing, whereas a language like C that was intended as a systems programming language
非常紧密且忠实地映射硬件和操作系统的语言会选择零索引的原因之一。我的意思是，显然 C++ 我想实际上不可能选择不同的选项，我的意思是，仅仅为了常规的原始指针访问，人们就不可能选择与 C 语言不同的选项，因为那样会极其不兼容；但同时，我认为也不会因为这个原因，
that very closely and faithfully maps to the hardware and the operating system picked zero indexing. And I mean, obviously c++ i think could not realistically have have chosen a different option um i mean one couldn't have chosen a different option from c just for like regular raw pointer access because that would have been wildly incompatible um but also i do not think it would have because of that it would would have been wildly incompatible. But also, I do not think it would have, because of that, it would not have been realistic for us to have our containers, our abstractions, not, you know, built in language facilities, but our abstractions be one indexed.
它不会是不兼容的。而且，我也不认为，正因为如此，我们的容器、我们的抽象——不是内置的语言设施，而是我们的抽象——采用一索引是切合实际的。
It would be really, again, it's better to be consistently wrong than inconsistent. It would be a very unfortunate world if std vector was one index, but pointers were zero indexed. Like, ugh. Yeah, yeah. And like, then what do you do about iterators? Because, you know, pointers are iterators. So that kind of suggests that they all have to be zero indexed. So it's almost like the high levelness or low levelness of the language
真的，再说一次，宁愿一直错得一致，也不愿前后矛盾。如果 std vector 是一索引的，但指针是零索引的，那将是一个非常不幸的世界。就像，呃。对，没错。而且，那迭代器怎么办？因为，你知道，指针就是迭代器。所以这某种程度上表明它们都必须是零索引的。所以这几乎就像是语言的高级或低级
should almost dictate which is sort of you know we just talked about that last episode is that uh apl super high level c++ super low level like the classic example that i run into in j or like an array language that's zero indexed is say you want to like the algorithm, which now exists in C++ 20 ranges, you're not using the zero indexing. Take zero takes nothing, and take one takes the first element. But in array languages, a lot of times you want to find the index at which the first element occurs, and so it's sort of like a take while.
几乎应该决定哪种是，你知道的，我们上期节目刚讨论过那个，APL 超级高级，C++ 超级低级——我在 J 中或像 APL 这种采用零索引的数组语言中遇到的经典例子，比如你想要那种现在存在于 C++20 ranges 中的算法，你没有使用零索引。take 0 不取任何东西，take 1 取第一个元素。但在数组语言中，很多时候你想找到第一个元素出现的索引，所以它有点像 take while。
You want to take up until that element you know, element and including that element. And if that index that is returned is zero indexed, you always have to add one to it in order to get take to work sort of inclusively. And yeah, I've always sort of whenever that happens, I'm like, this seems wrong. But anyways, should we get back to episode 53? Are you still struggling with why, I mean, 52 weeks we record or release at the, you know, either beginning or end of the week? And then 53rd is the? Yes, yes.
你想一直取到那个元素，你知道的，包括那个元素在内。如果返回的那个索引是零索引的，为了让 take 能够包含边界地工作，你总是必须给它加 1。是的，每当这种情况发生时，我总是觉得，这似乎不对。不管怎样，我们该回到第 53 期节目了吗？你还在纠结为什么，我是说，我们录制或发布播客是在一周的开始或结束？然后第 53 期是？对，对。
No, I was mostly being dramatic earlier. But it did, when I woke up this morning and was looking through the list of episodes, I was like, hang on a minute. Did Connor mess up? Oh, no. And did we already have it? And then my brain turned on. And this is the thing. I always state in the introduction when the podcast is recorded because I – this is like a thing that probably applies to nobody in the world except for me but I like I get in the habit of adding a podcast to my list probably the most recent one
不，我刚才大多是在夸张。但今天早上我醒来浏览节目列表时，我确实心想：“等一下，康纳搞砸了吗？哦，不。我们已经录过了吗？”然后我的大脑启动了。就是这样。我在播客介绍中总是会说明是什么时候录制的，因为我——这可能除了我之外对世界上任何人都不适用，但我喜欢养成把播客添加到列表里的习惯，可能最近的一次是我回去听了每一集的播客，我不知道是不是最近的，但我绝对听过 Cognacast，这是一个 Clojure 播客，所以我很难直接跳到第 120 集。我必须回到第 1 集或第 0 集，然后从头开始看。但因为那是 120 集，而且他们一个月发布一次，它的历史可以追溯到 2012 年。我喜欢知道在哪个时间点，Rust 刚出来吗，还是这是在 Rust 出现之前，我们所处的背景是什么，
that I went back and like listened to every single one I don't know if it was the most recent but I definitely did Cognacast which is a closure podcast so I have a very hard time like jumping into episode 120. I have to go back to episode one or zero and then watch them from the beginning. But because that's 120 episodes and they release once a month, it dates back all the way to 2012. And I like knowing at what point in time, was Rust just coming out or was this pre-Rust or what's the context that we're in here um which is why i always state the date that it's recorded because i think that's actually more important than when it's released
这就是为什么我总是说明录制日期的原因，因为我认为这实际上比发布时间更重要。我们不会受到发布时间的影响，我们受录制时间的影响。好吧，所以，呃，那是我和布莱斯关于数数的 20 分钟谈话，听起来差不多就是这样。我跟你说过这会变成一期关于数数的节目吧。但是，是的，我想我们还可以聊其他两三件事，所以我不太确定。我给布莱斯布置了家庭作业，让他挑选他认为的前三大或前五大节目。我没有认真做作业，我的意思是，我做了作业，但我大概是在加入 Google Meet 通话前三分钟才开始做作业的。我的意思是，我也没有完全给我的前三名或前五名排好名次，但我绝对知道。我知道我的其中一个，绝对是我最喜欢的一个是第 13 期。
like we're not impacted by when we release we're impacted by uh when we're recorded all right though so uh that was what 20 minutes of uh bryce and i talking about uh counting sounds about right i i i told you this was going to become the episode about counting um but yeah there's two or three other things i figured we could chat about so i'm not sure i gave bryce some homework to um pick what he thought were the top three top five episodes i didn't really do my homework well i mean like i did the homework but like i started doing the homework about three minutes before I jumped on the Google Meet call. I mean, I haven't fully ranked my top three or five either, but I definitely know. I know one of my, definitely one of my favorites is episode 13.
你知道第 13 期是哪一集吗？我是说，我正盯着列表呢，所以我直接跳到 13 了。我想让你猜的。我不知道，我想让你猜的。我想让你猜猜你觉得我最喜欢哪一个。好吧，我不看列表了——我的意思是，我现在知道了，因为我刚刚看了一眼，那是“我是一个 Excel 巫师”。对，对。所以，我喜欢那一集，因为我认为，一方面，它向听众透露了很多关于康纳的信息。另一方面，我喜欢它是因为我认为它对广大听众来说非常平易近人，因为几乎每个人都使用 Excel，即使你不是程序员。对，所以那是我的最爱之一。
Do you know which one episode 13 is? I mean, I'm staring at the list, so I just skipped to 13. I wanted you to guess. i don't know i wanted you to guess i wanted you to guess what what you thought my favorite would be okay uh i'll stop looking at the list like i mean i know what that one is now because i just looked at it but it's uh the i'm an excel wizard yeah yeah so so i like that episode um because i think one Because I think, one, it tells the listener a lot about Connor. And two, I like it because I think it's very accessible to a wide audience because almost everybody uses Excel, even if you're not a programmer. Yeah, so that's one of my favorites.
告诉我下一个数字。绝对的，我认为，在我们俩共同主持的节目中，我最喜欢的是。真的吗？我甚至不觉得那能进，我甚至觉得那不在我暂定的前五名里。虽然，我其实对它记不太清了，因为我觉得当时我处于一种恍惚状态，因为我太兴奋了，
Give me the next number. Definitely, I think, my favorite of the ones that's just you and I. Really? I don't even think that would have made, I don't, that wasn't in my tentative top five. Although, I don't even really remember it that well, because I think I was just in a haze because i was too excited um to be talking about excel i'll have to go back and re-listen to it um so episode 17 in 18 the first time we had sean parent on i didn't know those numbers i think that was that was just magical i mean every time we have sean on the podcast it's just magical what of the of i think we've had i think we've we've recorded with him three times and that's been turned into i think eight or nine episodes which of those um because definitely uh you know a couple of the sean parents are in like my top five um but i tried to only choose one and uh of those it's hard i i i really did like the first time we did it. I don't remember which of the like do guests well and like you know sean sort of knew the format then and
急着谈论 Excel。我得回去重新听一遍。所以第 17 期和第 18 期，我们第一次请到肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）。我不知道那些数字，我觉得那太神奇了。我的意思是，每次我们请肖恩上播客，都非常神奇。我想我们已经和他录制过三次了，这被剪辑成了八或九期节目。其中哪一期——因为绝对地，你知道的，肖恩·帕伦特的好几期都在我的前五名里——但我尽量只选一期，其中哪一期很难说，我真的很喜欢我们第一次做的那期。我不记得是哪一个——像嘉宾表现得很好，而且肖恩当时就差不多了解这个形式，然后
it's just like just awesome stories just like sean has just had it's like sure yes sean has had an interesting career but sean has also had like an interesting career that's just been he's just a magnet for these odd circumstances that just lead to great storytelling. Yeah. And so I think you're referring to episode 28, which is the well, actually, we won't ruin it, but it culminates in sort of Steve Jobs, you know, calling the CEO of Adobe with some things to say. So if you haven't listened to that episode, I'd probably say my favorite just because I had not heard. So several of the stories when we've had Sean on, I had heard over a CPP con,
这就像是太棒的故事了，就像肖恩拥有——这就像是，当然，是的，肖恩拥有有趣的事业，但肖恩也拥有这样一段有趣的事业：他简直是这些奇怪情况的磁石，这些情况总是能带来精彩的故事讲述。是的。所以我想你指的是第 28 期，那就是，好吧，其实我们不剧透，但它的高潮是史蒂夫·乔布斯给 Adobe 的 CEO 打电话说了一些事情。所以如果你还没有听过那一集，我可能会说那是我的最爱，因为我没听过。所以当我们请肖恩来的时候，有几个故事我在 CPP con 上听过，
which it's amazing to hear it for the second time because his stories are just so wild. But episode 39 where Steve Jobs, it's called How Steve Jobs Saved Sean Parent. Once again, I won't give away because I had no idea
再次听到感觉很棒，因为他的故事太疯狂了。但第 39 期史蒂夫·乔布斯如何拯救肖恩·帕伦特。再说一次，我不会剧透，因为我完全不知道那期播客会走向哪个方向。你知道吗？我一点也不知道那个故事。那一集实际上可能是我的最爱。我忘了他在那一集里讲过那个故事。对，那一集确实是。
that what direction that podcast was going. You know what? I didn't know that story at all. That one actually might be my favorite. I forgot that he told that story on that episode. Yeah, that one is.
我不会透露任何细节，但在某一时刻，我真的以为他要说有几个人死了。我直接就问了：“肖恩，每个人都活下来了吗？因为我们不能让你谈论你过去可能害死过什么人。”然后他说，接着他说：“不，不，不，大家都活下来了。”
I won't give anything away, but at one point, I legitimately thought he was about to say that a couple people died. And I like straight up was like, Sean, did everybody live? Because like we can't let you talk about how you potentially killed some people in the past. And he's like, and then he said, no, no, no, everybody survived.
然后我的血压稍微降了一点。我想：好吧。但是，是的，我想那只是因为我没听过那个故事，而且这也是——差不多是在这个播客开始之前，我意识到了关于肖恩的一件事，那就是他是所有这些关于史蒂夫·乔布斯等人的电影中的一个边缘人物，他认识这些在电影中被刻画的人。就像，他只隔了一层关系，如果他选择在苹果多待一会儿，
And then my blood pressure sort of dropped a little bit. I was like, okay. But yeah, I think that was just because I had not heard that story and um it's also once again yeah just sort of and that's the thing is that at some point it was before this podcast started that I realized about um Sean is that he's this like peripheral character in sort of all these movies that have been made about you know Steve Jobs and stuff is that like he knows the people that are being portrayed in these movies. Like, he's, like, one person removed, and if he had chosen to stay at Apple a little bit longer,
他可能就会成为电影中的人物之一，我只是觉得，我不知道。当我观看史蒂夫·乔布斯的传记电影时，我不会觉得，哦，是的，我认识与此相邻的人，但这正是，我不会觉得，哦，是的，我认识与此相邻的人，但这正是我所指的意思。我认为，如果仅仅说肖恩与此相邻，还不够慷慨。他，呃，是的，他一直在苹果和 Adobe 工作。不管怎样，关于肖恩的就说到这里。你的下一集是什么？或者你还有更多节目吗？
like, he would have been one of the people in the movie, potentially, which I just think is, I don't know. When I watch, like, the Steve Jobs biopic films, I don't think of it as, like, oh, yeah, like, I know people that are adjacent to that, but that's exactly what, I don't think of it as like, Oh yeah, like I know people that are adjacent to that. Um, but that's exactly what, what I mean. I think it's even, it's not generous enough to say that Sean's adjacent to it. He, um, yeah, he, he's been working at Apple and Adobe for anyways, enough about, uh, enough about Sean. Um, what's your next, uh, or do you have, do you have more episodes?
我喜欢第 19 期《在科技领域寻找你的方向》，我们在那里分享了我们的起源故事。同样，我喜欢这一集是因为它对任何受众来说都比较平易近人，我希望，我希望对某人有所帮助。同样，还有我们讨论“你应该退学吗”的那一集。天哪，你的节目怎么都和我的列表里的大不相同，这太有意思了。好吧，那我确实有几集更符合你可能会挑选的风格。所以第 25 期《丢失的归约（The Lost Reduction）》，我对那一集唯一的记忆就是我们在录制时是多么兴奋和热情。我觉得那其实是我们最长的一集，
I liked episode 19 finding your way in tech where we sort of gave our origin stories um again it's a it's an episode i like because it's sort of like accessible to any audience um and i i hope uh i hope was helpful to somebody um and likewise that the episode where we talked about should you drop out of college damn all of your episodes are so wildly different than than the ones that are on my list this is this is interesting well okay so i do have a couple that are that are more uh i think more what you might pick um so episode 25 the lost reduction um all i remember about that episode was being just so so excited and enthusiastic when we were recording it i think that i think that is actually our longest
这说明了一些问题。那是我们最长的一集吗？哦，什么，不，不，不。那是，与本·迪恩（Ben Dean）和托尼·维尼雷（Tony Venedere）的那期并列——不，不，不，不。它比那期多出了 19 秒。多出了 19 秒。我不能说我喜欢，但我认为它很好。我认为第 21 期《银河大脑（Galaxy Brain）》……哦，对，对。你考我的那一期。那绝对是我的前五名。
which says something it's our longest episode oh what no no no it's um yeah it's tied with the ben dean and tony veneered no no it, no, no. It's got it by 19 seconds. Got it by 19 seconds. And I can't say I liked, but I think it was good. I think episode 21, Galaxy being... Oh, yeah, yeah. Where you quizzed me. That's top five for me for sure.
未经提示就能说出来，真的是相当棒。而且，我喜欢，我喜欢包含式扫描（inclusive scan）那一集，第 37 期，总的来说，我喜欢我们所有谈论扫描（scans）或归约（reductions）的时候，这大概已经有至少五到十期节目了。这绝对是讲过最多遍的故事。布莱斯，我们已经讲过了。没关系。我们再讲一遍。我真的很喜欢第 51 期，
Unprompted was uh was pretty great um and um i liked i liked the inclusive scan um episode the episode 37 um and in general i like all of the times that we've talked about scans or reductions which has been probably at least five or 10 episodes. It's definitely the most retold story. Bryce, we've already told that. It's all right. We're telling it again. And I really liked episode 51,
《效率与速度》。对，那一集在网上收到了一些不错的反馈。我们以后得做一期后续节目。有人开炮了。你看到那条评论了吗，那是，那一集挺不错的。在网上收到了一些不错的反馈。我们以后得做一期后续节目。有人开炮了。你看到那条评论说“不好意思，但你真的懂预取（pre-fetching）吗？”的那条了吗？我不知道。我不知道那是谁，我也不打算去查，但你得，你得
the efficiency versus speed. Yeah, that's gotten some decent feedback online. We'll have to have a follow-up episode at some point. Someone shots fired. Did you see the one, that's, that was a good one. That's gotten some decent feedback online. We'll have to have a followup episode at some point. Someone shots fired. Did you see the one comment that said, uh, no offense, but do, do you even understand pre-fetching? I don't know. I don't know who that was and I'm not going to look it up, but you gotta be, you gotta
在 Twitter 上态度好一点。好吧，话说回来。我没看到那条评论。我敢大胆地说，我对预取的了解可能比那个人更多。看着那个人其实是某个架构师。好吧。所以这是我的。我的意思是，我没有按任何顺序排列这些。
be nicer. You gotta be nicer on Twitter. Um, all right, here's, right. I did not see that comment. I'm going to go out on a limb and say I probably know more about pre-fiction than that person. Watch as that person is like one of the architects of. All right. So here's my. I mean, I don't have these in any order.
我认为重合的一期是第 39 期，虽然我有点让你相信那是肖恩·帕伦特系列中最精彩的一期。超级惊讶你没有提到第 29 期——我是说，我知道我们都很喜欢肖恩，但那可能也算。钱德勒（Chandler）的故事与钱德勒从睡在车里/女朋友家（你知道的）、在棒约翰打工，到在谷歌获得火箭般窜升的经历相比，两者不相上下。我完全不知道。我的意思是，我想这可能是因为你比我更了解钱德勒，或者以前听过那个故事。这对我都新鲜。
I think the one that overlapped was episode 39 although i sort of convinced you that uh that was the most exciting of this the sean parent episodes um super surprised you didn't say episode 29 um i mean i know we love sean but that might even be it it's a close call between chandler's story of going from like living out of his car slash girlfriend's place, you know, and working at Papa John's to his meteoric rise at Google. I had no idea. I mean, I think maybe that was the thing is that you knew Chandler or know Chandler a lot better than I do. And it might have heard that story before. That was all news to me.
是的，但对我来说，公平地说，我已经听过了。好吧，肖恩的故事我大都听过了。第 39 期的肖恩故事我好像只听过一次，而且我甚至不敢确定。对。但那是，而且还有帕特里夏（Patricia）和钱德勒的那整个四部分系列，我也觉得很棒。是的，挺好的。所以。
Yeah, but like to me, to be fair, I've heard. Well, I've heard most of the Sean stories before. I think I've only heard the episode 39 Sean story once and I'm not even sure about that. Yeah. Yeah. But that's, and also just that whole four part series with Patricia and Chandler, I think is great. Yeah, it was good. So.
我们得找个时间请他们回来。是的。肯定的。然后，在我和你单独主持的节目中，之所以《丢失的归约》能名列前茅，很大程度上是因为它的滑稽之处——那是我们第三次还是第四次尝试录制那一集？我都快忘掉这一方面了。我都快忘掉这一方面了。我都快忘掉那一方面了。那是我们在最初录制完后我给你发短信说：“不，不，不，不，不。你得回来。”的那一集。对，我们需要做一个 10 分钟的补编。我是布莱斯。
We got to have them back sometime. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. And then of the sort of just you and me episodes, the loss reduction I think was up there more because of too like the hilarity of the fact that it was what the third or fourth time that we had tried to record that episode. I completely forgot about that aspect of it. I completely forgot about that aspect of it. I completely forgot about that. That was the one where I texted you after we'd originally recorded and was like, no, no, no, no, no. You got to come back. Yeah, we need to do a 10-minute addendum. This is Bryce.
现在我知道了，当布莱斯说 10 分钟时，他真正意思是大约 30 到 50 分钟。那个 10 分钟的补编，是的，花了大约 50 分钟。然后我们最终把它扔掉了，因为在最后，我想我们意识到，“哦，不，我们还是得把这个弄清楚。”所以，是的，有——但我们像，最终，我们还是弄明白了。对。最终我们弄明白了。所以，是的，《丢失的归约》，绝对的。
Now I know that when Bryce says 10 minutes, what he really means is like 30 to 50 minutes. The 10-minute addendum, yes, took about 50 minutes. And then we ended up throwing it away because at the end of it, I think we realized, oh no, we still need to figure this out. And so, yeah, there was- But we like eventually, eventually we got it. Yeah. Eventually we got it. And so yeah, the loss reduction, definitely.
银河大脑编程语言，对于那些没有看过或听过往期节目的观众来说，那是我考布莱斯，我想要么是八个，要么是九个，所谓在 1980 年代之前（或者可能在 19）发明的“银河大脑编程语言”，我想 1978 年，
Galaxy brain programming languages, for those that haven't watched or listened to the backlog, that was where I quizzed Bryce on, I think it was eight or nine, uh, quote unquote galaxy brain programming languages that were invented before, I think the 1980s or maybe in 19, I think 1978,
我觉得是最年轻的编程语言。所以布莱斯必须猜出它们。而且我想你，我想你猜对了。你绝对在五成以上。你的击球率在五成以上。
I think was the youngest programming language. And so Bryce had to guess them. And I think you, I think you nailed it. Uh, you were definitely above 500. You batted above 500. Um,
我不确定我是否会，如果我会——也许你把它剪辑得非常富有创意，让我听起来没有——不，我没有。我是说，最令人失望的部分——虽然你现在不会犯这种错误了——是你直到第七种语言左右才猜到 APL。是的，那是在你成为 APL 狂热粉的早期阶段。是的，这倒也是。那甚至可能是在这件事变得尴尬之前，因为那可能发生在我成为美国编程语言标准委员会主席之前。之所以说这会尴尬，是因为 APL 当然是由我担任主席的该委员会负责的标准语言之一。我想我们最近确实对 APL 标准做了一些处理。我不记得是什么了，但我似乎记得有这样的事情传到我的案头上。
I'm not sure if i would if i would maybe maybe you edited it very creatively to make it sound like i did not no i did not i mean the most disappointing uh part although you wouldn't make this mistake now is that you didn't guess apl until like the seventh language or something yeah that was that was like in the early days of you becoming an aplL fanatic. Yeah, that's true. And that might have even been before it was embarrassing because that may have been prior to me becoming chair of the U.S. Programming Languages Standards Committee. And the reason that would be embarrassing is because APL, of course, is one of the languages for which said committee that I chair is responsible for. I think we actually did something with the APL standard recently. I don't remember what, but I seem to recall something like that crossing my desk.
是的，为了凑齐这个列表，第 47 期节目，我可以就组合逻辑（combinatory logic）大发感慨，这是我当时最喜欢的话题。然后可能我和你之间最喜欢的时刻是在第 45 期，当时我忘了你是个鸟类爱好者。然后在那一瞬间，那种兴奋感可能是我自你提到肖恩·帕伦特将出席我所在的某个会议之类的事情以来最接近的一次。或者可能就是这样，你说：“哦，我在 CBP con 的主题演讲期间可以介绍他，”
Yeah, I have no to round out the list, episode 47, where I just got to wax rhapsodic on combinatory logic, my favorite topic of the moment. And then probably my favorite moment just between you and me was on episode 45, when I forgot that you were a big fan of birds. And then in that moment, it was probably the closest I've been that excited since you mentioning that like Sean parent was going to be at a conference I was at or something or something like that. Or maybe that's what it was is you said, Oh, I could introduce him during his keynote at CBP con,
结果没有发生。然后不管怎样，你说：“哦，对，我喜欢鸟，”然后我当时就想：“哦，对，”然后当我——我忘了我们在录音时有多兴奋，当我在剪辑和聆听时，我只是笑得前仰后合，笑自己怎么会这么亢奋——不管怎样，我们会把所有这些节目的链接放出来——我的意思是，如果你从一开始就在听，那么你刚刚听到的只是我们在谈论你已经听过的内容。但如果你是一个新听众，如果你手头的目录为空，这些可能是你想要回去听的节目。
which didn't end up happening. And then anyways, you said oh yeah i love birds and then i was just like oh yeah and then when i was like i had forgotten how excited i got when we recording and when i was editing it and listening to it i was just like killing myself laughing um at how how amped i got um anyway so we'll put all a link to all of those um i mean if you've been listening from the beginning then then you've just heard us talking about stuff you've already listened to. But if you're a new listener, those are the ones that you might want to go back and listen to if you have an empty catalog.
如果你是一个老听众，你可以回去重新听这些节目。事实上，回去听个 10 遍吧。是的，事实上。用不同的设备，带有独特的，是的，当你在家工作时，只要在 VPN 上访问我们的网站，你知道的，点击那个播放按钮，把它静音，或者不要静音，你知道的，也许，并且确保通过 VPN 连接到——是斯洛文尼亚吗？哦，对，斯洛伐克，斯洛文尼亚，两者之一。我敢打赌我们做得相当不错。当时我们大概排在第 13 位，我们一定是，我们一定是那种顶级科技——那里一定至少有一个国家，那里有，有多少个国家，世界上有 206 个国家，还是说这是人体骨骼的数量？我总是记不清。
If you're an existing listener, you can go back and re-listen to the episodes. Like, in fact, go back and do it like 10 times. Yeah, in fact. From different devices with unique yeah while you're while you're working from home just uh while you're on vpn hit up our website you know just hit that play button put it on mute and or don't put it on mute you know maybe uh and and make sure to vpn into was it slovenia oh yeah slovakia slovenia one of the two i bet we're doing quite well we were like number 13 at the time we've got to be we've got to be the one like the top technology there's
我知道非洲有 54 个国家，因为我读过一本行为经济学书，里面教你猜测 90% 的经济学书。那可能是理查德·塞勒（Richard Thaler）的书之一。是的，为了考精算师，我实际上不得不读一堆这类的书。但他们有这样一个——我母亲在成为律师之前是一名经济学家，所以第一，当我开始，从非常小的年纪起，我们的晚餐餐桌对话就是关于经济学基础的简短讲座；第二，我对经济学有一种奇怪的喜爱，我听的很多播客都是经济学播客。
got to be at least one country there's what 200 is there 206 countries in the world or is that bones in the body i can never remember um i know that there's 54 countries in africa because i read a behavioral economics book where they tell you to guess a 90 percent economics book. It might have been one of the Richard Thaler ones. Yeah, I had to actually read a bunch of those for my actuarial exams. But they have this like my mother before being a lawyer was an economist and so one um when i was like starting like a very young age our dinner table conversation was like brief lectures in uh the fundamentals of economics and two um i have a strange affinity for economics and like a lot of the podcasts I listen to are economics podcasts.
是的，行为经济学确实是迷人的东西。我最喜欢的一本可以说是鸿篇巨制，丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Daniel Kahneman）的《思考，快与慢》。他们描述了可能是我最喜欢的现象之一，叫做“峰终定律”（peak-end rule）。基本上它是说，你对一次经历的记忆在很大程度上是由它的结尾和它的最高峰决定的，所以你知道他们说的一件事是，你尽量不要——你知道的——用争吵来结束一次美好的度假或类似的事情，因为你对那一天的记忆很大程度上会是那场争吵之类的；他们做的研究是让人们把手浸在真正冰冷的水中 60 秒，然后他们用
Yeah, I mean, behavioral economics is fascinating stuff. One of my favorites is a bit of a tome, but Thinking Fast and Slow by Daniel Kahneman. They describe probably what's one of my favorite sort of phenomenon, which is called the peak-end rule. And basically it says that your memory of an experience is largely defined by like the end of it and the peak of it so that you know sort of one of the things they say is you should try not to like you know end a great vacation day or something with a fight because you're largely going to remember that day by like the fight or something and the study that they do is they get people to submerge their hand in really ice cold water for 60 seconds and then they do the
同一群人做同样的实验，但时间是 60 秒，然后在后面加上 30 秒，这同样是冰冷的，但温度高一度，然后他们问你在这两者之间你更喜欢哪个？其中一个是另一个的超集，所以它们显然应该——你知道的——如果它们是完全理性的并且能够体验事情（按其本来的方式），它们应该只喜欢 60 秒的极冷，而不是 90 秒的极冷加上极冷加一度；但绝大多数人，比如 90% 以上的人，都更喜欢以稍微暖和一点的温度结束，尽管它仍然让人不舒服，我只是觉得这太棒了。所以，这就是峰终定律。我有很多这样的例子。
same experiment um with the same group of people but they do it for 60 seconds and then uh add 30 seconds afterwards which is also freezing cold but like one temperature warmer and then they say what do you prefer between the two so one of them is a super set of the other one so they should clearly just you know if if they were you know perfectly rational and could experience things you know the way they were they just they prefer the 60 second freezing cold instead of 90 seconds of freezing cold plus freezing cold plus one degree but largely overwhelmingly like i think 90 plus percent of people prefer ending on the slightly warmer, even though it's still uncomfortable, which I just think is fantastic. So peak end rule. I got lots of those.
是的，54 个国家。我知道这一点，是因为其中一本书讨论了人们如何极大地低估置信区间（confidence intervals）。所以如果我让你对某个客人在哪里给出一个 90% 的置信区间，也就是两边各有 5% 的概率你猜错了，大多数人不会这样做，他们极大地，他们认为自己知道的范围比实际要近得多。像经典的例子，我的意思是，我已经把答案说出来了，所以被我毁了，但他们说，你认为非洲有多少个国家？平均而言，人们认为大约是 20 或 30 个。当你让他们给出，当你让他们给出一个 90% 的置信区间时，他们会说：“哦，好吧，20 或 30 个。好吧，我们说 25 加上或减去，比如两边各 15 个，也许，也许两边各 20 个，”
And yes, 54 countries. I know that because one of the books talks about how people wildly underestimate confidence intervals. So if I asked you to give like a 90% confidence interval of where there's like 5% on either side that you're wrong about some guests, um, most people don't, they, they wildly, they think they know they're way closer than they are. And like the classic example, I mean, I've ruined it because I've already said the answer, but they say, how many countries do you think are in Africa? And on average, people think it's like 20 or 30. And when you ask them to give a, when you ask them to give a 90% confidence interval, they go, Oh, well, 20 or 30. Okay. We'll say 25 plus or minus, like maybe 15 on each side, maybe, maybe 20 on each side,
但即使两边各 20 个也是 5 到 45。大多数人只会加上或减去 10。所以你得到的范围是 15 到 35，而结果却是 54。但事实的真相是——你为什么觉得非洲有 20 或 30 个国家？——事实是，哦，你知道，北美有几个，所以非洲有更多的国家，对吧？所以它一定像，什么，比如，乘以 10 或者是别的什么。但事实的真相是，你真的不知道，如果你不知道，你就应该说 0 到 100，你知道的，这是我的 95%——或者你知道，比如 2 到 100——我几乎可以肯定是，非洲绝对不止一个国家，而且我相当确定世界上有一半的国家也是。另外，我们没有回到——我们完全扯远了——206 是不是人体的骨骼数？
but even 20 on each side is five to 45. Most people will only do plus or minus 10. So you get a range of 15 to 35 and it turns out to be 54 but the the truth of the matter is is like do you why do you think there's 20 or 30 in africa like the the truth is is that like oh you know there's a few in north america so it's like africa's got a lot more countries right uh so it's got to be like what like you know times 10 or something um but the truth of the matter is is like you really don't know and if you don't know you should just be like zero to a hundred you know that's my that's my 95 percent uh or you know like two to one hundred like i'm almost positive there's no there's not one country in africa and i'm pretty sure half the countries in the world also too we didn't get back to we're totally on a tangent here 206 is it bones in the
但即使两边各20个，也是5到45。大多数人只会加减10。所以你的范围是15到35，结果是54，但事实的真相是，比如你为什么觉得非洲有20个或30个？事实是，比如哦，你知道北美有几个，所以非洲肯定有更多的国家，对吧？嗯，所以它大概应该是，比如你知道乘以10之类的，嗯，但事实的真相是，比如你真的不知道，如果你不知道，你就应该觉得比如是0到100，你知道的，这就是我的，这就是我的95%的信心，或者你知道的，比如2到100，因为我几乎可以肯定非洲绝对不只有一个国家，而且我很确定世界上有一半的国家也是如此，另外我们还没有回到正题，我们刚才完全扯远了，206是多少来着，是骨头的
body or countries in the world you know i think it's i have no clue i think it's... I have no clue. I think it's countries in the world. Let's look it up. And also, too, how many bones do I think in their body? Probably... Well, that also kind of depends on how you define countries. I mean, Google will tell us a single number, guaranteed. And I'm going to say bones in the body are... 95.
身体还是世界上有多少个国家？你知道，我想... 我毫无头绪。我想是... 我毫无头绪。我想是世界上有多少个国家。我们查查看。还有，我觉得人体有多少块骨头？大概... 嗯，这也取决于你如何定义国家。我的意思是，谷歌肯定会告诉我们一个具体的数字。而我要说人体内的骨头有... 95 块。
Oh, shit. Oh, sorry. I swore. It's what Google says. Countries in the... Again like i think that there's different counts depending on how you count country there's 195 un recognized countries in the world but i do not i think that the actual number is uh uh slightly more than that i was wrong yeah so it was 206 bones in the body um it's a sad day. It's a sad day.
哦，天哪。哦，抱歉。我说脏话了。这就是谷歌给出的答案。至于... 同样的，我认为根据你如何计算国家，会有不同的统计结果，世界上有 195 个联合国承认的国家，但我不认为... 我觉得实际数字比那个... 稍多一点。我猜错了，是的，所以人体有 206 块骨头，嗯，这是悲伤的一天。这是悲伤的一天。
All right, so we can do... There's two more things. So this is going to be a bit of a longer episode. We'll probably keep it as one, though. So do you want to do a little APL++ play along? Because this is going to wind back to a great point that I want to make.
好的，所以我们可以... 还有两件事。所以这将会是一个稍微长一点的单集。不过我们可能会把它作为一期节目。那么你想做一点 APL++ 的互动游戏吗？因为这将引出一个我想表达的精彩观点。
Why are we doing this on the year anniversary? Because I want to. and it's going to be awesome. Connor is the editor, so I have no realistic say in this matter. He's also got a very evil grin right now. So, listener, oh boy. I have to say,'m not i'm not devastated the last time i was devastated was when i injured my deltoid ligament to my left angle length ankle a month and a half ago
为什么我们要在一周年纪念日做这个？因为我想这么做。而且这会很棒。康纳是剪辑师，所以我在这件事上实际上没有什么话语权。他现在还露出了一个非常邪恶的笑容。所以，听众朋友们，哦天哪。我不得不说，我并不... 我并不是很崩溃，上一次我崩溃还是在一个半月前我的左脚踝三角韧带受伤的时候。
i was devastated then um i'm probably like 20 as devastated as i was back then. But what just happened? So we've been recording for almost an hour and 40 minutes. And at the 44-minute mark, at which point we hadn't even gotten to this huge journey that we went on where I walked Bryce through a BQN solution to a leak code problem. Oh, we missed all that? I'm pretty sure because the part that was where it got lodged was when you were looking up partition in programming pearls. And then I locked,
我当时崩溃了，嗯，我现在的沮丧程度大概只有那时的 20%。但刚刚发生了什么？所以我们已经录制了将近一个小时四十分钟。而在第四十四分钟的时候，当时我们甚至还没开始那段漫长的旅程——我带着布莱斯（Bryce）了解了 LeetCode 问题的 BQN 解决方案。哦，我们错过了所有这些吗？我很确定，因为卡住的那部分是你正在查阅《编程珠玑》里的划分（partition）算法。然后我锁定了，
I think I knocked it out then. And so we hadn't, I think you had probably said the solution in C++, but we hadn't even gotten to the BQN stuff. So I think we lost all that. And it was gold. It was gold. I all that and it was it was gold it was gold i mean and it was it's it's it was done in such a way that uh it's not going to have the same effect the second time around because you're going to under you're going to understand we can do we'll do it but um
我想我当时把它碰掉了。所以我们还没... 我想你可能已经说出了 C++ 的解决方案，但我们甚至还没开始讲 BQN 的东西。所以我认为我们失去了所有那些内容。那是黄金内容。那是黄金内容。所有的那些，那是黄金，那是黄金，我的意思是，而且它的完成方式是... 第二次做就不会有同样的效果了，因为你会理解的... 你会明白的，我们可以做，我们会做的，但是...
uh oh yeah so i gotta say wow it's uh my heart my heart hurts a little bit that's the thing is a week ago or whatever we had to re-record. But we were talking about sort of a... You would think that production quality would go up while you were doing this, but no. My defense is that I was so excited about this that I just was moving all over the place. And oh, man. Oh, man. Yeah.
哦，对了，所以我得说，哇，这... 我的心有点痛。事情是这样的，就在一周前左右，我们不得不重新录制。但我们当时在讨论一种... 你会以为在这个过程中制作质量会提高，但并没有。我的辩护是，我对这个太兴奋了，以至于我到处乱动。天哪。天哪。是的。
And that's the thing. When you were about to explain something and then i was like wait a second wait wait a second i i knocked out my mic thing that probably stopped audacity and then i went and looked and then bryce was still like he was like oh i think i know i think this is what's happening and then i was swearing in the background and like i was like bryce no we gotta bryce you gotta stop and he was like oh no, no, we got to stop. And he was like, oh, no, what? Yeah. But it's okay because we're going to have an awesome future episode where we're going to completely redesign Thrust's partition algorithm now that we've discovered that it is subpar.
事情就是这样。当你要解释什么的时候，然后我说，等一下，等一下，等一下，我把我的麦克风装置碰掉了，那可能让 Audacity 停止录音了，然后我去查看，然后布莱斯还在说，他当时说，哦，我想我知道，我想这是怎么回事，然后我在背景里说脏话，就像我说，布莱斯，不，我们得... 布莱斯，你得停下来，然后他说，哦不，不，我们得停下来。然后他说，哦，不，什么？是的。但没关系，因为我们未来会有一期精彩的节目，我们将彻底重新设计 Thrust 的划分算法，因为我们发现它其实不够理想。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢这期节目，并祝你有美好的一天。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。